welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and now that marvel's eternals is
available on disney plus everyone is now
coming to terms with the wild
implications of that movie's finale
namely what the hell happens to earth
now with a massive celestial corpse
towering into the stratosphere like we
all got so caught up in spider-man no
way home's memory logic that those runes
of cough calm also made us forget that
even more destructive to the status quo
of the mcu is this baby planet killer at
least on a seismic geological ecological
atmospheric not to mention psychological
scale earth is broken so the real
question is did marvel intentionally
make this mess in eternals in a no way
home to f up earth so badly that it must
be rebooted in multiverse of madness let
us explore how badly diamond's corpse
broke the world and why explain
so according to airshim in eternal
celestials are born from seeds planted
inside of planet cores and then they
gestate feeding on sentient life on the
planet's surface until the population
reaches the critical mass and the
celestial hatches killing everything on
the planet when airship showed this
process to cersei it happened relatively
fast but in the climax of the film the
emergence is much slower starting with
tiamat's upreaching hand and then just
the top half of his head cersei
transforms his golden form into pure
marble and we even see the lights of his
eye holes extinguishing leaving now this
massive marble corpse in the indian
ocean but how big exactly is tiamat well
according to the film's vfx supervisor
matt aitken from weta digital they
estimated team it to be 500 kilometers
or about 300 miles from his head to his
toes to be precise 500 kilometers is 311
miles but judging from the full body
shot of tiamat halfway through the film
the top half of his head that's a part
that later juts above sea level amounts
to about eight percent of his overall
height that would make the part of
timoth's head towering above the indian
ocean to be a height of 40 kilometers or
about 25 miles for context mount everest
is 8.8 kilometers or 5.5 miles meaning
the top half of tiem its head is four
and a half times taller than mount
everest the tallest mountain on this
planet to put this in an even scarier
context the earth's troposphere where we
live and breathe and all weather events
occur is 18 kilometers or 11 miles above
sea level above that is the ozone layer
which ranges from 15 to 40 kilometers or
20 to 25 miles above the planet so yeah
tiamat has broken through the ozone
layer into the stratosphere that would
mean a devastating effect on weather
conditions uv radiation and ocean tides
and that's to say the least because
really this is a question of mass and
mass displacement inside of the planet
in the earth beneath tiamat's body
because tima gestated from a seed
planted in earth's core earth's
planetary diameter is 12 700 kilometers
or about 7 900 miles and the core layer
of this planet really begins at about 2
900 kilometers or 1800 miles beneath our
feet so if timid is 500 kilometers or
311 miles tall and we're not really
accounting for how wide or thick he is
just by height alone that's four percent
of the diameter and that is a lot of
cubic feet of mantle rock that timut
displaced as he emerged which would
cause massive explosions of rock
elsewhere on the planet in
continent-sized sinkholes in other areas
it would almost certainly destabilize a
magnetic charge of the planet throw it
off of its gravitational axis and yeah
just caused the whole planet to break
apart as shown in aeroshem's vision even
if only tiamat's hand and head broke
through so yes applying real world
physics too much should have just broken
the earth and getting into mit should
have been the least of peter parker's
worries now of course it is easy to just
shrug this off as even the vfx artist
does in the interview he says the logic
and the scale are really just based on
the needs of the sequence and that's
completely fair it's a movie really i
think the more insane choice is that the
eternals film just leaves marble tiamat
there all in one chunk as seen in news
footage at the end of the film i love
how it looks but it wasn't the only way
this film had to end cersei transformed
huge boulders into birds she could
transform any material into any other
material she could have dispersed to tim
it's form into something more malleable
to fill back in those holes like sand or
gravel or cookie dough now a huge thanks
to hellofresh for sponsoring this video
with hellofresh you can get fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your door
they make home cooking easy fun and
affordable that's why it's america's
number one meal kit i'm busy you're busy
we all busy hellofresh offers a wide
variety of quick and easy recipes
including 20 minute meals easy clean up
and low prep options hellofresh helps
keep things simple with recipes and
ingredients that cut out grocery
shopping and limit meal prep time so
that you can spend more time with
friends and family or you know just
finally finishing that 4 000 piece lego
death star no shame in that it's a
perfectly valid way to spend your time a
lot more of what you're gonna have to
say hello fresh with hellofresh produce
gets from the farm to your doorstep in
under a week for peak freshness
hellofresh has more five star reviews
than any other meal kit so you know
you'll get something delicious hello
freshest pre-portioned ingredients mean
there's less prep for you and less
wasted food i just got a hell of fresh
delivery made a wonderful pasta dish it
was awesome so go to hellofresh.com and
use code rockstars 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three surprise gifts now one
solution i think is fun is that the
avengers could use this corpse as their
new compound as they did in the comics
with the massive corpse of the celestial
the progenitor which became avengers
mountain equipped with wakandan tech a
circulator transportation system a brain
room and a prison in the gut which is
where i imprison cookie dough since
avengers compound was destroyed in
endgame we don't really know what
facility the avengers get to use now
other than the sanctums of new york and
camartage borrowed from the sorcerers
but i doubt that will be the case since
even marvel executive nate moore
indicated in an interview that elements
from the eternal's film don't have to
come back in future marvel titles which
is a very rare tone for a marvel
executive to use they're almost always
like we'll see anything and everything
could come back but uh not here to me
this signals that chloe zhao and her
team were unleashed to go for broke in
the way they leave the planet in
eternals the same way if you think about
john watts and his team were allowed to
bizarrely gaslight the whole universe
and spider-man no way home and the best
reason i can see that these titles being
allowed to burn the house down when it
comes to world logic is that marvel
studios at the end of the day plans to
reset this universe anyway in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
because we know it was the celestials
and airship's plan to allow earth to be
destroyed so that temet could be born
and when the eternals thwarted that plan
some of them were whisked away for
judgment but right after tiamat's
emergence they unpack how that happened
tim it joined our unimite
i always wondered how we survived the
destruction of other planets that we
were on
by being connected to the celestial as
it emerged
yeah while fastos frames this as a kind
of loophole they stumbled into hijacking
a celestial link coded into their reboot
protocol makari's line reframes it with
gratitude a choice tiamat might have
made to allow them to survive at his own
expense sacrificing himself for
something more important now a more
cynical mind could just view makari as
naive like thanking a newborn who
actually was ready to dust them off like
afterbird but i'm with makari here i
think this gen z celestial baby knew
something that its boomer forefathers
didn't because timoth fed on the
sentient life of earth and that sentient
life included a link with its most
knowledgeable residents who is more
sentient on earth than dr strange who
overloaded his brain with multiversal
knowledge to bypass thanos or more
sentient than wanda maximoff who's now a
scarlet witch nexus bean possessed with
an even deeper knowledge of the
multiverse tiamat knew what strange
knows what wanda knows the opening
scroll of this movie explained that
celestials pre-date the big bang and
therefore supersede the six infinity
stones so combine that cosmic hive
knowledge with the nature of the
universe with everything tement has now
learned from doctor strange and one of
maximov's multiverse experiments and
timoth must know that these two terrans
on this eggshell rather than just being
blown out of existence instead are super
important the future of this universe
and need to be preserved to fix and to
rewrite this reality into the new world
that it will look like after this coming
nexus event and that new world could
include timoth's corpse being erased
from the indian ocean could include
whatever kevin feige wants the mcu to
know about spider-man and could include
anything else marvel studios wishes to
improve about this planet in the mcu
like the fact that there aren't enough
mutants on it so there you go the
physics of tma rotting into our
stratosphere and why he actually did us
a huge favor by doing this
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
rockstars subscribe to new rockstar some
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching out for us baby
teammate
[Music]
you